so I just want to make sure I mention 72
seasons is the new album and uh and
which which how many albums has this
been this is 11 right
I'm not the one to ask because
yeah it's somewhere because it's getting
your manager for several years
which is uh much appreciated but it gets
into all that stuff about you know the
live albums count do the cover albums
count you know was it the the the level
does your phony phone calls album count
exactly
and The Jerky Boys yeah I want it
but you know so all that stuff about
whether uh you know so I I don't know
it's it's we you know we're we're not
the most prolific of the bands out there
because we like to tour and and we we
like to do so many things but you know
we've done a couple movies and we've
done a couple live albums and we do you
know we did an incredible uh uh project
with Lou Reed a few years ago and so
we're always up for whatever but it's
somewhere around 11 or 12. give or take
it's not 20 or 30. and you're starting a
two-year
tour M72 tour
um and uh Matt I want to go to a show
with you because I would like please no
I really do I'm asking since 2007. I
know but you always ask when there's
work to be done
well now that things are winding down I
can finally I wonder where they were
when they're winding down no one told me
I don't know you said there was always
work to be done
we're doing we're doing a couple nights
in August we start we we start in
Amsterdam and we're doing Europe in
April May and June and then we start in
America uh in August and go up to I
think November so a couple nights so far
thinking yeah it's a two-night
commitment yeah also different set each
night yes and of course of course the
band's gonna want me to come out for a
set with my acoustic guitar
um let there be no question about that
now you playing Georgia Satellites with
Metallica
[Laughter]
if you've ever seen and we're gonna
bring the truck out from the video
if you ever want to if you just to have
this experience once because you've had
the experience of making these massive
crowds of hundreds of thousands of
people deliriously happy if you ever
want to have the opposite reaction just
for fun just say hey everybody Conor
O'Brien is going to come out now we're
going to interrupt the show and he's
bringing his acoustic guitar and then
you're gonna see people as I start to
play file out they will file out now
they'll come back the next night we have
our version of that it's either you know
when we need to clear the house it's we
do a drum solo or we you know whatever
there's there's multiple versions of
that but if you want to come out and
help clear the house the stage anytime
you feel that you want to get rid of the
crowd quickly let's say there's an
emergency and you need the crowd out of
there I will come on stage and uh I'll
sing Aqualung
um
[Music]
I mean it reminds me I was talking to
somebody interview a couple days ago we
were talking about our history of La uh
and I mean we've had some of the the
best shows of our career in LA because
the the fancier is so passionate
uh and obviously you know going back to
the knec days with that was the first
real hard rock station I was going 24 7.
you know in an area like real hard rock
um
but
Long Beach Arena
uh what are those 16 000 seats in there
we've paid for about 15 000 of those 16
000 seats over the years because every
time we would play Long Beach arena
people would just you know take the
cushion uh you know uh start some frisb
you know play Frisbee with it inside the
arena and next day would be like uh okay
uh Metallica here's a 300 000 worth of
cushion shopping that we had to do for
you know wait you you have to pay for oh
yeah we I had to go on James and I
had to go on knec multiple times and go
listen whatever you know you're our fans
and and we're your fans and we're all in
this together and we want you to have a
good time and we support that but
understand one thing when you're
rebelling if you think you're rebelling
against the building or rebelling
against Authority or rebelling against a
man or whatever the it is you think
you're rebelling it the only people
you're really rebelling against is
Metallica because that that that bill of
fifteen thousand new seat cushions comes
right back to us which is fine you know
so but we had a similar situation a
couple years later at LA Coliseum I
don't know if you know we were playing
uh and there was uh whoever had booked
the LA Coliseum show at that time things
were
maybe uh slightly more unpredictable
about sort of the the physical elements
of the makeup of these shows and in
front of the stage the whole lawn or the
you know the football field at the LA
Coliseum
was all folding chairs
so uh I don't know if any of the six of
you would like to guess were 40 000
folding chairs
about you know three songs into the set
yeah yeah that's right all those uh
whatever there was 30 40 000 folding
chairs ended up on stage and you gotta
come in and so we had to stop the show
as as all these folding chairs were
being I mean it was I mean you're
talking you talked earlier Conan about
like you couldn't script some of this
yeah yeah I mean you really
couldn't scripted a comedy show and I
didn't know that uh it was lawn dart
night 35
000 people had a lawn dart underneath
their chair I was killed I'm a ghost now
that's where this story goes
um anyway I like the idea of Metallica
having to stack neatly the folding
chairs
guys we're gonna cut creeping death
short right now we'll be back in in 30
minutes
talking to James Hetfield and saying no
no no that's there's still seven
cushions unaccounted for you're not
going anywhere